special counsel john durham dropping a
bombshell that could lead right back to
hillary clinton a court filing alleges
multiple clinton campaign staffers hired
a technology company to quote infiltrate
servers at trump tower and then later
the actual white house in order to try
to establish a link from donald trump to
russia and breaking this afternoon
sources telling fox news that durham's
probe has accelerated with more people
cooperating and coming before a grand
jury republicans say it is proof they've
been right all along and that heads
should start rolling
this is what's so egregious and so wrong
about it i mean you think about they
spied on a presidential campaign that's
as wrong as it gets but then we found
out from this filing that they actually
spied on a sitting president which is
even worse i would expect there to be um
frankly
quite a few more uh indictments i think
this conspiracy and i do think there was
a criminal conspiracy
um uh is is broad and and deep
and after endless coverage of the russia
investigation the media seems to be
silent on this particular development
and the way they covered the durham
investigation in the past is drawing
even more scrutiny
the biggest scandal was when they spied
on my campaign they spied on my camera
there's no real evidence of that of
course there is it's all over the place
leslie they spied on my campaign and
they got called donald trump and william
barr promised that durham would expose
huge corruption but he hasn't done that
is apparently an ongoing concerted
republican and pro-trump project
to try to turn the investigation of the
russia scandal into some kind of scandal
itself oh no okay wait till the durham
report comes out and
and then nothing happens and they just
move on to the next conspiracy theory
i could just keep watching that montage
but we shall take it around the table
judge what about this development that
fox news is reporting that there is
additional cooperation that's happening
which is why this is sped up a little
bit well that that's that makes sense in
a situation like this i think you know
everyone who is a potential defendant
knows who they are in these cases and
they are probably recognizing that
they've gotten to the guts of this look
this was an attempt to frame a
presidential candidate and the president
of the united states to frame him as
being a russian operative a putin puppet
and if you recall
the damage here is unbelievable we've
never seen anything like this and
america was torn for four years we were
at each other's throats because hillary
clinton her campaign hired people to try
to make a connection between a server in
the trump tower and one at a russian
bank uh that's connected to putin i mean
this is outrageous and you know this
woman who's always smiling and and you
know is like you know i'm i that donald
trump is evil and i am the great
salvation the truth is she's been
through more criminal
quasi-criminal activities from erasing
33 000 emails
that many of them classified saying she
never had a classified email on her
laptop or her iphone when that's when
she was a secretary of state and she's
got all of these problems and now
they're getting to the guts of it and i
think by trying to frame the president
of the united states every american
should be furious and every potential
defendant out there knows that they're
coming for you and does that include i
would assume hillary clinton harold who
is going to be one of the speakers at
the new york state democratic convention
and has flirted with the idea of running
again this seems to lead right back up
to her door in 2016 she put out a tweet
saying oh why look at this there seems
to be a connection here but it seems
like they were fabricating the
connection in the first place to drive
news coverage
if these allegations by mr durham turn
out to be true the ones that have been
leveled against i believe these two
lawyers and maybe even a third lawyer uh
you have to let the chips fall where
they may fall i'm a rule of law person i
believe the constitution all that rule
of law derives from that i'd be careful
to before we go so far as to link her to
this and i've heard some people inflate
the rhetoric and said you know quite
between watergate and here but remember
president nixon approved and uh actively
engaged in the cover-up if that is
proven uh judge or for anybody around
the table anybody watching uh mrs
clinton will have a lot to answer for
before we go there and make that leap
with her
i think what we have on the table alone
is is disturbing so you're saying it's
obama who's behind this i'm saying the
three the two or three lawyers that mr
durham has leveled these charters with
and said they've went out and perhaps
hired someone to infiltrate then
candidate trump servers
that should disturb any american any of
us who believe in the rule of law and
any believe that politics should be
litigated on the up and up
if that is proven again let the chips
fall where they may you know one of the
reasons they figured this out greg is
because lawyers bill for their time
and when you go back through the billing
records you find out that they were all
billing it to the
trump hillary campaign amazing and this
is worse than january 6 9 11 watergate
hindenburg combined
that's what cnn would say if this in
fact were trump and not hillary in this
case they are focusing instead on joe
rogan
claiming that his use of the n-word was
another january 6. this is another
illustration of the news spigot like
when with mueller
the the the legacy media can turn that
spigot up full it just blasted 24 7.
then the hunter laptop turn the spigot
off everybody's like what happened
where'd it go uh biden wins an election
you don't hear about hunter biden then
trump flushes paper down the toilet
spigot comes up and it hits you in the
face and now you got this collusion you
got real authentic russian collusion
this is all about hillary and the spigot
goes off this is something that you know
we see this every day uh you saw it look
they accu and also
they blame you for the things that they
do so it is like you know you're you're
putting kids in danger while they don't
wear the masks they accuse you of racism
while saying that you know the toxic
toxicity of whiteness is everywhere and
in this case they created a hoax when in
fact they were behind the hoax creating
a different hoax yeah in order to drive
new news coverage yes but then everybody
would follow uh interestingly that mark
elias is this attorney that everyone
should pay attention to democratic mark
elias perhaps um
you know democrats are even mad at him
because of screwing up the arizona case
so when you hear cooperation it sort of
means to me that some people just don't
want to go to jail so they started
talking i think hillary should be
banished from polite society i'm not
comparing her to oj because you know we
have no proof that she ever murdered
anybody but i would like to see hillary
treated the way oj is you know he's not
really welcome places he's kind of a
pariah
right now she is a certified political
political criminal her husband has been
metoo'd and has been fingered to be on
epstein's island and you know the
foundation was you know that's just like
a washed up money laundering operation
this is what happened she paid people to
hack into trump's computers and frame
him for being a russian trader
that would be like paying someone to
break into trump tower at two o'clock in
the morning plant a bunch of guns and
drugs and russian documents and then
call the fbi and said hey guys i got a
tip once you go raid the tower that's
the same thing
and we now know too that this was
happening as far back as 2014 the cia
knew crooked was trying to frame him
they briefed obama that hillary was
going to frame him they briefed the fbi
that this was a frame job so mueller was
just a cleanup operation to tee up the
impeachment and it failed so
it's not i think you know greg was being
facetious i think but when you look at
january 6th and then you look at this
what did more damage i mean think about
how many people's lives were destroyed
how it divided the country how it made
us question our democracy question the
election and our institutions it ruined
multiple
thanksgivings for me personally and you
know i think we need to get to the
bottom of it as they say greg big if
true yes you know who else worked on you
who worked on the watergate committee
who remember
hillary herself that's right right full
circle as they say and a lot of people
want hillary investigated not just
republicans even democrats not just
independents democrats hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else